with all the talk about the quarterback
class would forget about
that three you know thirty percent three
tenths
of the top ten could be wide receivers
could have three quarterbacks and three
wide receivers possibly
in the top ten to talk about that and uh
everything about the nfl draft before he
heads off to cleveland be part of nfl
network's draft coverage
is steve smith senior how are you sir
what's going on i mean that's a setup to
be able to follow dj on that
good well look we had him on in november
to break down uh the best uh
football player uh on film uh and you
know
he nailed it um so yes he did and i just
wanted to play that just to let everyone
know that he's ready for draft week too
so man that was i was listening and at
first i was like
ooh and then i started to follow on it's
like oh my god
like when you hit through with the wheel
of demon i was like
i'm looking through my paperwork i'm
missing him
yeah his comp uh willie beeman's comp is
uh jamie foxx
so uh that's his comp yeah he looks just
like jamie it's kind of crazy
um so let's get into the wide receiver
conversation with you steve and let's
start with the
defend with the heisman trophy winner
that's in this group
uh devonta smith and the conversation
about him
is his weight being a buck 66
and whether that automatically discounts
him from being drafted in the top ten
i'd love to give you the floor on this
subject matter
you know that's interesting and uh i i
kind of feel bad for them
you know because this process until
somebody
actually picks them that's the purpose
of this process
of is t to debunk
and also just kind of bring forth
the the strengths the weaknesses and
really with the summarization or summary
of
uh of devonta smith the one thing that
i'm looking at
that you know he may not want to look at
and hear that
is his size and
of course a guy and my stature they're
going well how can you say
there's a difference between size and
build
and i think what people are looking at
is is devante smith's
build and his build when and when i'm
talking about build i'm talking about
you know you look at
a guy like um uh
elijah moore five nine you know he's 180
190
right and looking at some of the things
that other guys are doing five
nine jaylen waddle five nine one eighty
right and then you looking at some up
some of these other guys nicole
uh nico collins six four two fifteen
why is that all play into into what's
going on well
when you're gonna draft possibly in the
top six he can go anywhere from
one through six and and possibly six or
seven doesn't pick him he can drop even
lower into the fifteens and twenties and
here's why
what position has he played primarily in
college he's played in a position where
he's moved around a lot
right and when you move around a guy a
lot especially in college
there is a learning that you have to
adapt to
a learn a learning curve and then that
learning curve if you already
uh what we call or you know what what
adults call or parents you know hey i
got i got one kid that's lighting the
pants
well if you're playing football and
you're
a fist fighting a phone booth that's
what dbs and and wide receivers do on
that island on the outside pressed up
you got to be able to take one and give
one and
when i look at his stature and i look at
him i look at his
glutes down to his cankles
it ain't a lot of meat back there it's
not it's not
it's not sick he's fast but what's going
to happen when he's going against a
jalen ramsey who's 262
uh six feet 200 something pounds and you
166 pounds and a dude is 215
benching 225 25 times and he hits you
one good time and your little small
shoulder pads come unbuckled because the
only thing holding it up is sweat
that's gonna that's gonna wear on you
and then over
77 plays that over time
now if he plays in the z where he's on
playing where the z with the tight end
he's off the ball so they can put him in
motion
but if he's in the x stationary stand
and he has no motion to get him free he
just has to be able to beat the corner
one-on-one
create his own play yes he did it in
college
hooray that's great but can't that
doesn't guarantee
the carryover in the national football
league and i think that's what teams are
looking at that's why teams have a
legitimate question
and he has opportunity wherever he goes
he gets
however long he gets to play he gets a
legitimate opportunity to prove all the
people like myself and you and everyone
else that says maybe
he may have been too late at 20
something years old which is the case
but he can grow into his body how much
how thick and how big he will grow into
his body
will ultimately be up to him in a way
and a strength of coaching staff
or whatever organization he goes to but
it is a legitimate
question when you're handing out a
couple of millions of dollars
five nine you were coming out of utah
did you have questions about your size
absolutely you had questions five nine
176 pounds of course
i'm also i i haven't gotten taller
however five nine 197 at the height of
when i was lifting and started to get a
lift and i was about 205
to 2 uh 202 and guess that was the year
that i took i actually tore my
hamstrings three times
right because my body frame cannot
sustain that much
weight so my ideal weight was about 195
and i was strong enough and i was it my
body could sustain it
and how i know even at 42 when i'm
a little heavy around like most people
thanksgiving christmas
right when i'm a little heavy first
thing goal starts to
let me know that i'm heavy is my back
and when my back starts to get tight
when i'm doing a regular stuff that's
when i know i'm getting too heavy
that's just knowing my body my body is
when i was playing was at perfect
strength speed and endurance and
durability
about 195 and 197 if i got below 195
or i got above 197 my body started to
talk to me
tightening of hamstrings quad growing
hip flexors
all of those things did that and that's
the that's why you get paid millions of
dollars and you're considered a
professional athlete
high octane to be able to know how your
body can operate and what fuel you need
to
fuel up this expensive engine so
what you're saying is normally an uh a
teams
coach uh general manager and
maybe owner gets on the phone with the
prospect before they draft him saying
are you ready to join this team
you're saying that whoever drafts
devante smith it could be the strength
and conditioning coach that gets on
first saying are you ready
i mean like literally that's what you're
saying i don't think that'll happen but
i know that'll be the first or second
person he meets once
he's in a facility they are going to
have to see what he does well
what he doesn't because you you notice
in all his stuff
he didn't bench he didn't do this he
didn't do that because of those question
marks
smart on his part but eventually you're
gonna have to get in the weight room
they're gonna be
they're gonna need to see what you can
and can't
what you can and can't do and and and i
didn't lift a ton of weights i used a
lot of body weights i did a lot of my
workout
regimen with a weight vest on so i
wasn't
huge into the lifting weights because
back in the day
you know in 80s and 90s what they say if
you
if you lift weights too early you start
your growth well you know i'm on a low
man
uh chart so i didn't want to stunt the
growth that i was gonna receive
so i did lift weights but as i got older
and i got with
with the team i got my own uh trainer i
started to figure out how i can lift a
lot of body weight
a lot of weight vest to get me strong to
be powerful
but not making myself so bulky that i
lost
mobility and became stiff in my hips and
my joints steve smith senior here on the
rich eisen show
um so jamar chase is the consensus best
receiver on the board if you're the
bengals do you reunite him with um
with joe burrow or do you get borrow the
protection at the tackle position
you get joe you give burroughs the
protection he's recovering from a knee
injury
no quarterback can throw the ball
efficiently and comfortably
especially after you just got your knee
taken out and you got surgery if you
don't
uh protect them you got to protect it
you see what the what the
chiefs did they decided hey let me go
ahead and trade
for a guy who doesn't want to be on the
team we need a left tackle
our left tackle um my grammars couldn't
block a shadow
and and that's why you know patrick
mahomes was running 400 and something
yards
not advancing the football but just
ripping and running around
the field just to save his life so he
could be a dad before his daughter's
born so
you know just just little things like
that oh i'm getting in rare form
wow i like it i'm ready for steve smith
part of our draft coverage so how
special is chase then
what do you think of him i think there
is i think he's
fantastic there's a lot of wide
receivers in this draft
that are fantastic i've never seen
an off i've never seen a draft thus far
that you're talking about the first fit
out of the first great at 50 players
i mean 16 or 17 of those players are
going to be offensive players
some of the defensive players in
nashville the last time we were all
together
all those guys that were drafted in a
first round defensively
man these guys would not be drafted in
the position they were drafted in this
year's draft because it's so
heavily offensive-minded players
and a static so i think what i really
love
all these big rangy tall
stiff six three six two 210 212 pounds
and those guys are going to be so far
back i love the fact that you got
elijah moore from ole miss five nine
right you got some guys that are barely
six feet uh
jaylen wado he's five nine like all
these guys
are little guys that are to go out there
and make so many plays and i'm excited
the six ones the josh
uh josh palmer heck of a wire receiver
for tennessee
he's gonna be down there uh in in in the
third and fourth round because
you just got so many young speedy
athletic shifty
difference making play makers uh that
are
below six feet and i'm excited to see
you know see that
so steve smith is kyle pitts the best
receiver in the draft
he is a tight end darn it she is a tight
end
okay and yes that's a
bad man i
i listen guys like that like gronk
uh you know other guys in the league
tight end kelsey
and those guys just take other passes
away from from wide receivers but those
guys in there rightfully so
they're difference makers and they you
have to account for them
in the past game and he obviously get
with a team that will improve his
uh blocking skills but really he's a
threatening passing game and that's all
you need to know
so who's the justin jefferson you think
in this draft who could be the kid
the kid taking bottom half of the first
round in the 20s
um who has a chance to just be so
dynamite that he's the offensive rookie
of the year
what do you got for me i think i like
elijah moore i think he can be but i i
think also too
rich you you would agree hopefully is
and if you go to the right team
and that makes the biggest difference
right
because if you go to a team
that just doesn't have the
understanding of what type of player you
are
you can it can start your growth big
time so having a right team
that understands how they should look at
a player just because he's the best
available
he has to be best available in your
system
because if you're just grabbing a player
because he's the best available and then
you don't know what to do with them
that that's just not good ball that's
that's just not smart
drafting that's that's no direction and
that's what gets teams in trouble like
the jets
like the bangles in the past where
you're just grabbing a guy because
his his his 40 time is awesome but he
can't catch a cold
he can't run good routes and you don't
have a really good system to
uh really enhance what's what his pros
are and and to limit what he doesn't do
well
so outside of the chiefs uh who's got
that
system that you think would just be any
receiver goes there they'll be lucky
what do you got for me on that whoo
you know what i mean if if the 49ers get
their stuff together i mean
if they can add another guy in the rough
like
that go to match with uh deebo and all
you know
samuels and nayuk and i mean that's a
team there's a
what what happens if if if the vikings
actually get their stuff together what
what about carson wentz you know if he's
together
and they got this dynamic run game going
and all of a sudden they got this young
class of receivers who could who now you
add another one or tight end or somebody
they can get going there's a lot of
teams out there
that can just how fast can they get
things together
um when you say get things together for
the vikings is that is that code for
cousins is that what that means
steve no i think i think cousins hasn't
been getting a fair
shake okay cousins has done a great job
you know he's up there in the upper 70s
and completion but the defense has
really let them down
um cousins won a playoff game and
everybody just kind of went
went quiet nobody said anything so i
think he's been i'm just talking about
collectively how the deep how the
vikings
are defensively they were not the team
that we expected them to be and their
and cousins was doing this was doing his
job
but the defense you know left him
hanging at times
so before i let you go steve you know
earlier this week i said you know matt
ryan's going to be a nervous guy
this week certainly on thursday night
seeing what the falcons are going to do
and
you know i asked carson palmer what's
going through his mind youth
in palmer gave us a great read of what
could be going through
matt ryan's mind i'd love to ask you
with the report that teams are calling
to see if julio jones is going to be uh
acquirable because he's a salary cap
casualty and ryan might be there and
they could draft pits they could
actually take a quarter what do you
think is going through julio jones's
mind right now
steve smith well it's a new it's a new
general manager a new head coach
they've obviously had a conversation
hopefully
you know a number of conversations and
they probably presented this to him
and maybe he you know and they let him
know he let they let him know or he let
them know that he you know he wants to
move on
and that's what that's what's on the
table
i i don't really know it just depends on
what teams
are kind of interested unless to to
really know
how excited he is matt ryan
won't be replaced this year but i would
tell you this
the atlanta falcons need to get a
quarterback at some point because here's
why
look at the quarterbacks that are
available in 2022.
mitch trubisky marcus mariota
my main man ryan fitzpatrick the minivan
himself
right there is a lot of guys
that are just going to fill a gap
but that isn't who they want
to be long term with a new general
manager and a new
head coach or second year head head
coach or second year general manager
that you want
a veteran he's a veteran on the streets
for a reason and it's not because well
he just didn't get along with his
offense coordinator
there are some deficiencies these
individuals on that list
potentially will be and you don't want
your professional career that just
started a year and a half ago
to be on the line because now you need a
quarterback
there's no quarterbacks coming out of
the draft next year that are
like these guys and there's definitely
no quarterbacks
that are scheduled to contracts to
expire
in 2022 that makes everyone
run to the bank and make sure they uh
sell
some stocks and shares so they have
enough money to sign this these guys
those guys aren't on that list all right
i'll bite you you call
uh you call fitzpatrick minivan because
he's been everywhere or
because he's full of children what do
you got for me
i got both he's been everywhere right
and and guess what what for a long for a
long family trip
that's your guy but he's not gonna win
any
you're not gonna go far like it he's not
a guy that you
from charlotte to florida i'll take ryan
fitzpatrick
but if i'm going to europe i'm not
rolling with
ryan fitzpatrick steve smith senior your
a game is already sharpened and i cannot
wait to see you in ohio in a couple days
with the rest of the crew on nfl network
thanks for the call steve
appreciate it you bet that's steve smith
senior
have you ever heard fitzpatrick called
the minivan i have not i have not the
nfl's minivan
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here